le président du groupe LR ici au Sénat
on vient de vous entendre lorsque il y a
quelques minutes c'est-à-dire à peu près
10 minutes vous avez demandé que l'on
utilise le règlement du Sénat son
article 38 pour venir contraindre les
débats quel était votre intention avec
cet article 38 mais attention c'est
dénoncer l'obstruction ça fait 5 jours 5
nuits qu'on a juste à une multiplication
de prise de parole des centaines
d'amendements qui sont parfaitement
identiques et je vois bien que la gauche
qui voulait pourtant arriver à l'article
7 qu'on le discute le 7 mars on l'a fait
et bien là il y avait une forme de
blocage il faut qu'on aille au bout du
texte parce que il y a des articles qui
sont si importants pour les Français moi
je veux discuter de la retraite des
maires de famille je veux discuter de
l'usure professionnelle des petites
retraites de la surense vieillesse par
exemple pour les pour les aidants c'est
ce que j'ai indiqué je pense que
finalement
l'obstruction c'est pour le Parlement la
négation de son rôle c'est une sorte de
49,3 à l'envers c'est un autodésissement
du Parlement on a entendu le chef de
file des socialistes vous dire honte à
vous vous voulez bâillonner votre
position c'est un scandale qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondez mais j'espère que les
téléspectateurs ont depuis cinq jours et
5 nuits écoutez et ils ont vu qu'on a
rien bâillonné du tout qu'en réalité
l'obstruction c'est une vieille ficelle
qui consiste quand on a pas une majorité
à essayer de bloquer les débats on peut
pas bloquer les débats pour bloquer un
vote voilà il y a une règle en
démocratie il y a des minorités il y a
des majorités recourir à des artifices
de procédures pour en calaminer les
débats pour moi ça n'est pas la
démocratie parlementaire quand on est
parlementaire on n'appartient pas un
groupe de parole vous voyez où on
parlerait à l'infini notre job à nous
notre métier c'est de débattre et pour
voter la gauche vous alerte sur le fait
que on risquerait de porter atteinte à
la sincérité des débats avec cet article
38 qui je le rappelle est une première
son utilisation depuis sa création ou
son instauration dans le règlement du
Sénégal qu'est-ce que vous répondez là
encore j'ai un archi et très bien
répondu cet article a fait l'objet
précisément d'un contrôle du Conseil
constitutionnel et à l'issue de ce
contrôle du Conseil consuel le Conseil
n'a rien trouvé à redire sur la
constitutionnalité de l'article 38 ça
signifie donc que nous pouvons
l'employer à sans doute une exigence
près c'est que les oppositions aient pu
débattre et puis s'exprimer ce qu'ils
ont fait durant 5 jours et 5 nuits de
façon quasiment continue qu'est-ce que
ça va changer très concrètement pour
noter les spectateurs à partir de
maintenant vous le dites c'est fini
cette obstruction cordiale de la part de
la gauche le monologue de la gauche est
terminé va pouvoir avancer beaucoup plus
vite dans le texte c'est pas avancer
vite c'est simplement avancé c'est qu'on
ne nous empêche pas de discuter des
articles qui sont importants je les ai
cités tout à l'heure sur l'usure
professionnelle sur les Invalides sur
par exemple les maires de famille ou
encore sur les toutes petites retraites
juste un dernier mot là-dessus est-ce
que vous allez défendre vous encore et
bien cet article 7 ou est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'on avance et qu'on passe
cet article 7 ah bah il faut voter sur
l'article 7 bien sûr mais déjà ce que
j'observe c'est que il y aura pas de
suppression d'articles 7 c'est donc une
première victoire il ne sera pas
supprimé maintenant c'est acté puisque
c'est voté merci merci beaucoup Bruno
Retailleau chef de file au Sénat on va
rejoindre notre journaliste